oh
[Musique]
où
l'odeur de peinture est encore présente
situé à quelques mètres du château de
versailles la salle du jeu de paume a
été entièrement restauré d'une salle de
sport et d'amusement ce lieu devient un
site emblématique de l'histoire de
france a souhaité une salle très
importante en fait surtout à l'heure où
on parle beaucoup de citoyenneté
d'appartenance républicaine on est
vraiment dans l'enceinte même entre ses
quatre murs ou s'est proclamé le serment
le fameux serment du jeu de paume ce
fameux serment prêté le 20 juin 1789
devient le symbole de la révolution
française et de l'abolition de la
monarchie et c'est à la salle du jeu de
paume effectivement que les constituants
vont
décréter le fait de ne sortir de ce lieu
que une fois que la république aura été
affermi sur socle solide fermé depuis
juillet 2021 pour être rénovés la salle
du jeu de paume rouvre ses portes ce
vendredi 1er avril tout a été refait du
sol au plafond vous constaté par exemple
que le sol a retrouvé son état d'origine
que les coursives on retrouvait
également leur fraîcheur première que
toutes les les murs ont été assainies
mais aussi les bases de la salle qui
souffrait d'humidité les travaux ont été
financés par les députés à hauteur de
1,8 million d'euros les visiteurs
pourront découvrir ou redécouvrir la
statue du président provisoire de la
toute nouvelle assemblée nationale jean
sylvain bailly les bustes des députés
qui ont participé au serment du jeu de
paume ainsi que l'oeuvre d'olivier
merson immortalisant ce passage
fondamental de l'histoire de france
[Musique]